I became intrigued with pixels because I
loved the idea of the story basically
about three videogame enthusiasts who
win the world video game arcade
championships and in 1982 a space
capsule was sent into space with all the
current events one of them was the world
video arcade championships the aliens
saw that and took the games as a
declaration of war
sending down huge live-action versions
of those things to destroy our planet
while the military's helpless against
these things the only people who can
save our planet are these three video
nerds and that's what I loved about it
[Music]
and I was excited because the scrip had
centipede sequins and a pac-man sequence
what the first draft of the script did
not have was Donkey Kong after months
and months of meeting with the board of
Nintendo they agreed that we were gonna
treat Donkey Kong with respect and the
proper gameplay which was very important
and bringing Donkey Kong into the film
was the slam-dunk for us the visual
effects in the film really were the most
difficult part of making this film there
when it creates something the audience
has never seen before and at the same
time we had to push ourselves to a new
place in terms of visual effects we had
to create interactive effects that were
CGI that existed within a realistic
environment I wasn't interested in
creating an all CGI environment that
feels a little false to me what I loved
about like a movie like the original
Jurassic Park is that you have tangible
things so when we do the pac-man
car chase we did all of that practically
we added pac-man later Donkey Kong was
an amazing amazing set you'd walk into
this giant green-screen stage and the
Donkey Kong set was built the girders
were life-sized we put the actual actors
on there in harnesses jumping over where
the barrels would be and it was
physically exhausting but it made the
sequence much more exciting
something interesting is a lot of our
audience probably not born with pac-man
or Donkey Kong first released are
becoming obsessed with going to see this
movie they've found a way to fall in
love with these characters that's very
exciting so now you've got adults who
played the games the parents can take
their kids to the film who are
interested in the games they have this
shared bonding of learning about these
games I love the fact that this is a
love letter to gamers you know the fact
that these guys who everybody thought
were losers at the time suddenly become
heroes don't tell anybody I killed the
SMERSH
[Music]